こんにちははじめ社長ですボコ見覚えのある弾でが多いと思います
前のプールですあのを覚えている方もいると思うんですけども僕
カラーモール5万パールですよ家に
外道がなくて一番ぐらいずーっと5万物編に押し込んでいる状態でなんか壊滅ないから
ですと思ったんですけども
思いつきました夏といえばクールじゃないですかただ空路を言ってその水を張った
プールにカラーボールコマンド入れたら
water for のコラボレーションすべてせ気持ちいいし
ボール打って上げられるしもうもりなちゃん飛び込んださぁさぁなし水をパッシャンっ
て史上最高のくれていると思ったわけなんですよ二役なのはコレだっ
売れないんですけどもまずは2
抱卵ん
[音楽]
car
me
もうちょっと点蔵付近まで来たんですけどまず全部この部屋から出します
[音楽]
持っています
ええええええ
[音楽]
me
あれはゲーから来ました
あんなんだと部屋がこんなことに新居屋の抹茶待って待って待ってやばいやばいやばい
これヤバイってますやんまじでやばいなこれ
ってかなあこのまとめてちょっとトラックに積む移動されます
me
ん
いやあーいやいや
多いなぁいやすげーどうだよ
[音楽]
怖いよん
me
[音楽]
ああ
[拍手]
rar
ani
みたいと思います
ああああああ
はぁっ
me
goo
ええええええ
[音楽]
[拍手]
ああああああ
[音楽]
[拍手]
rar
aname
[拍手]
[音楽]
あるんだああああああ
[拍手]
[音楽]
4 bandana ああああ
時ですよ
[音楽]
padi
聖市中央